[Music]
chuck
yes
ask me where wind comes from oh i know
uh it's it's my uncle
and uh
dude thinks it's funny he's kind of rude
doesn't make a difference if we're at
the table or not it's terrible doesn't
apologize and doesn't apologize or
nothing
sometimes he's proud of it not
cool not cool
not cool
okay uh asking about meteorological wind
oh okay
where does meteorol meteorological wind
come from
i will quote ogden nash
ogden nash
yes yes the playful poet
agnes wind is caused
by trees waving their branches
that guy was stupid
[Laughter]
let me tell you right now i do not know
where wind comes from i'm gonna be
honest i don't know where wind comes
from but i know this much
it don't come from trees waving
hey how y'all doing
how would you know because
and i'll tell you this is important
there's a bit of science here okay you
own how do you when it's windy out
trees are swaying right so how do how
would you test what the cause and effect
is of that
because two things one wind could be
caused by fast spinning anemometers okay
the
wet the weather vanes it could be you
know
it could also be caused by a butterfly
flapping its wings in japan
a big butterfly
mothra
tokyo
um
no the the reason is because
i hear the wind and then i see the tree
move
so that means the wind was their pain
about what sequence you obtain data
the wind didn't hit your ear first and
the tree is waiting for it to get
through your head and then hit it
sometimes it does sometimes i hear the
wind and then i see the tree move i'm
like that's something rainbow
something came by me and moved that tree
those are the trees a quarter mile away
be
all right so no this is very uh it's
actually very simple okay uh you have
wind
which is a re
adjustment of air pressure that's really
what's going on okay
i don't see you say it like that me
you say it like that just explained it
to me
sorry okay
no no what you have is uh basically a
readjustment of air pressure that's
that's all that's what it is
that's all it is we're down here
no thanks so is the on
equal heating of earth's surface oh now
that makes sense that's
that's what it is okay that's cool and
so if it's warmer in one place than
another
and plus earth is rotating
so
these factors conspire
so that if air ever rises
well that wouldn't cause wind as we know
it because wind goes horizontally to the
surface but if you have rising air
because it just got heated what happened
what has to happen next
you don't you don't create a vacuum
below well you do but then what happens
you have falling air
sorry yes
if air rises you'll also have falling
air right that's true
in total but the pocket of the the
pocket of atmosphere directly below
where the air had gone up
okay what happens there oh it has to be
filled
it's got to be filled so you get an
updraft it gets filled from the sides
right
from the sides
yes
oh my god that's how it works
yes that's so cool
[Laughter]
so you have rising air it creates a
partial vacuum other which is a pressure
difference and then other air says we
have to fill that gap let's go there and
so there it goes
okay nice
so if you look at hurricanes for example
very very low pressure in the middle
you have heated
warm
warm moist what we call unstable air air
is unstable it rises okay
in that low pressure system all the
clouds in the neighborhood want to go
there
sweet every everything wants to go to
the center of a hurricane it's the cloud
nightclub
yo man you going to the eye tonight you
going to the eye
yo
yo man i heard the eye is going to be
hot tonight
[Laughter]
so all the clouds try to come in but
then earth's rotation
sort of
veers them to the right
no matter which way they're trying to
head into the front entrance of the eye
club um
they they veer to the right and so you
have this circulation
while the clouds are trying to get to
the middle and this gives you that
that's that that spiraling storm that
spiral effect
that and everybody trying to get into
the middle and so so hurricanes have
famously
fast winds
because of this
like hundreds of miles an hour in in the
fastest of them fastest of them now
if you have
if you have
air
that is descending
okay
air that descends first it won't make a
cloud
okay so descending air is like generally
clear skies deserts have descending air
oh okay
now there's certain parts of the world
where
the descending air is so
sort of total
it is sort of gently descending and it
can go out the sides but if the area of
the descending air is large enough then
there's no sideways wind
wow
these areas of earth's surface
especially over the ocean
are called the doldrums
that's the club that nobody wants to go
to sorry you got the hurricane eye yeah
and you got the devil exactly it's like
man i couldn't get into the eye last
night now i gotta go to the dolphins
the doldrums so the doldrums are regions
of earth's surface where all the wind
has ceased
and if you happen to be a sailing ship
that wanders into the doldrums wow
oh my gosh that's bad stuff that's it
that's it
many a ship
have just
given up the ghost in the doldrums
because you can't you can't move and if
they don't have oars
uh and there's no wind nothing
nothing and they eat up their food
supply they eat each other whatever and
that's it
wow it's like the great it's like the
great wind garbage patch of the ocean
like the plastic patch
it just
accumulates it goes nowhere
there's the wind versus part of it that
way yeah that's terrible it's a
fascinating fascinating disturbed
analogy it is
oh that's terrible though
now a couple of things couple other
things
so
mars has famously
large wind storms
and we call them dust storms because the
wind picks up the dust you know the
martian
surface dust
yeah yeah and so you can see this in
fact when it happens it cloaks
the martian surface and so our
telescopes and space probes we can't see
what's at the bottom it's basically one
of these like sandstorms you've read
about in the desert
but it's like a dust storm on mars or
it's a very clever cloaking device that
the martians use to stop us from looking
at them when they're doing stuff on the
surface of mars
yeah exactly truck
[Laughter]
but do you remember the face on mars
listen do you remember the face on mars
uh so it was back in the 70s there was
like the famous face on mars it was like
some kind of a like a structure that had
eye sockets and nose and a mouth and
it looked like a huge m it was huge huge
and we got a couple photos of it during
the viking missions and everyone said we
got to go back clearly there's life
there okay by the way if there's life
and that represented it it would have to
be life that had sort of a simian face
like most life on earth doesn't have a
face so that would be weird if life on a
whole other planet had a humanoid face
that that would just be weird okay just
saying but because lobsters don't have
what did we notice the lobster monument
that was there no because we're only
looking for stuff that looks like us all
right so we went back
and you saw and we had better higher
resolution you saw a hint of like where
the eyebrows were in the mouth but it
was mostly
sort of and people said the martians
knew we were looking at them yeah
covered it up they covered it with their
mars dust
here's my point
uh the martian atmosphere is 1 100th
the thickness of earth's atmosphere oh
that's terrible there's that's barely
it's barely any atmosphere so if you
move that air 100 miles an hour
yeah you ain't got yeah yeah
it's like uh
it's like a it's like an infant trying
to blow out a birthday candle you know
just
it's like
i'm giving up and that's why the whole
scene
in the movie the martian where they
can't leave they're trying to leave the
planet
come on dust storm is coming
and then
the rocket is rocking come on it's
rocking back and forth and they take off
and they get and they gotta leave mark
wadney on the surface because they're
afraid they'll topple over from the wind
ah man another movie ruined thank you
neil
no yeah that can't happen then right
that just can't even happen
yeah yeah it's not yeah it's not
happening you might be dusty and you
can't you can't see yeah but you're not
blowing over any spaceships so it's also
not gonna it's also not gonna pick up a
rod a metal rod
and spear you with it because
it's not gonna do that either
yeah it's it's not tornado speed right
right so the point is mars is also an
unevenly heated planet right and that's
why you get and
correct correct all right wait a minute
wait wait wait wait what i gotta ask you
this now all right and this is off the
explainer chart but i gotta do it okay
i know that you know him
so did you ask him about that when he
wrote this
like you're talking about um andy weir
andy yeah
did did you actually ask him
i got all up in his situation but then i
what i said was what i said was okay
andy so much else in that novel
later the movie was
was so well calculated and thought
through
i'm gonna give you a hall pass on this
one oh okay because without it he's got
no story
yeah he's got he had to do it was it was
poetic license for a mars hurricane so
he could get to the rest of the story
yeah so i gave it to him because he did
the rest of his homework see i'm not
totally evil
commentator
i will cut you some slack if you're an
artist as as mark twain said
first get your facts straight
then distort them at your leisure okay
that's mark twain's edict so i'm all in
on that by the way venus
is very evenly heated over its surface
and we think it has hardly any winds
there at all nice
yeah yes uh yeah it's it's
it's a refreshing 900 degrees
well you would vaporize but ignoring
that complication
no wind needed no wind needed
it's so even it's so easy
it's not a dry heat it's an even heat
you're good
[Music]
that's the joke i heard about hell they
say that you know you ask some evil
person how's hell yeah yeah it's it's
it's it's hot but it's low humidity so
we're [ __ ]
that's funny actually
chuck we gotta end it there this is this
is a a windy
starting off with your uncle
yes we had a windy
a windy explainer for star talk dad
[ __ ] always surprising
neil degrasse tyson here
keep looking up
[Music]
you